au moins deux façons de pénétrer dans le
grand théâtre de tours par la grande
porte majestueuse avec cet escalier
monumental si typique de l'architecturé
du 19e siècle
et puis il ya cette autre entrée plus
discrète à l'arrière du bâtiment qui
ouvre sur une petite cour modeste et
soigneusement caché à la vue du public
d'ici on voit la majorité des activités
de préparation d'activités parallèles ce
que le spectateur ne voit pas et ne doit
pas voir nous voici au coeur des
ateliers c'est là que sont fabriqués
tous les éléments de décor ici on soude
on découpe on perce on assemble ont
peint touré l'un des derniers opéras de
province a disposé à six de ces ateliers
sur son site historique
évidemment l'exiguïté des lieux pose
parfois quelques problèmes de
manipulation mais la situation présente
aussi quelques gros avantage les
machinistes constructeur de l'opéra tour
asie ce aussi bien sur scène en
manipulation de décor que en atelier en
création de décors donc cette
polyvalence elle se traduit très
concrètement par une meilleure gestion
ergonomique de la fabrication puisque
les gens qui fabriquent les éléments
savent c'est eux qui vont les manipuler
l'un des peintres décorateurs réalise un
faux marbre pour la future tosca vue de
la salle l'illusion sera parfaite
y'a pas un projet scénographique qui
ressemble à un autre
donc on refait on ne refait jamais
quasiment la même chose du d'un ouvrage
lyrique à un autre donc voilà cet aspect
2 mai de curiosité puis d'innovation à
chaque fois c'est la partie des parties
les plus intéressantes du travail court
mais qui tend un instant le grand
théâtre
quelque part en périphérie de la ville
nous découvrons cette immense hangar
[Musique]
une vingtaine de décors d'opéras et
stockés derrière vous cosi fan tutte
juste ici bérénice appel mais joey joie
certes certains éléments de macbeth bon
voila j'ai vu un mozart là bas ces
décors qui nous ont fait rêver nous les
retrouverons demain sur une autre scène
pour présenter une autre oeuvre avec
d'autres métiers tout aussi important
c'est grâce au rôle propre à chacun que
le spectacle peut trouver toute sa magie
[Musique]